eight five percent of the attacks
nowadays are based on compromised
identities machines or users so I think
that the world and the situation shout
out loud and said okay we need a change
and this is where we uh gave birth to
resonates that resonates security into
identities and from identities to the
entire business cycle here we are
challenging the uh the old systems and
like bringing a new approach to cyber
security
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
[Music]
thank you very very much for being
yellowy I'm really excited to to talk to
you today about about your journey about
resonate and looking at Cloud resources
and infrastructure core and identity and
access and previously you're you're the
vice president of product and incubation
at Cyber reason you were also in the
prime minister's office in the global
cyber defense operations and and of
course education from MIT MIT Sloan and
so really an amazing background and I'm
excited to to under to learn with you
how you've channeled a lot of your
learnings and understandings into
resonate and what's happening today in
the Cyber Cloud environment so again
thank you for being here that sounds
awesome thank you
so so talk to me about the for
foundation of of the resonate I mean
you've you've done a lot in the
cyberspace where are we at in 2022 that
lead you to create this company
well there's a major shift to Cloud
nowadays like it's uh the shift started
a few years ago uh but it's like soaring
and soaring and even with recession is
going up and up for cost saving for uh
increasing the velocity of building the
business and this shift from endpoint
Centric and network Centric to Cloud
Centric kind of like called out for
changing the party game of security and
an identity of users and of machines
became the new vantage point for both
attackers and Defenders now we've
challenged the uh the current approach
and we saw a lot of retrofit of
Technologies of the old days like into
the club doesn't work 85 of the attacks
nowadays are based on compromised
identities machines or users so I think
that the world and the situation shout
out loud and said okay we need a change
and this is where we uh gave birth to
resonates that resonates security into
identities and from identities to the
entire business cycle
um yeah and like here we are challenging
the uh the old systems and like bringing
a new approach to cyber security
incredible okay and so you've you've
gone through you know different Cycles
with organizations and so you're you're
starting resonate tell me a little bit
about you know really the pain point
that that resonate is coming to solve an
identity and access
great so uh in the shift to cloud and to
soft Centric businesses we kind of see
that there's a shared security model
that has been changed with transitions
tons of the security responsibility to
the vendors of the apps of the cloud
native of the third parties I've been
working with
the only thing that left that we are
fully controlling or on is the
identities which is who is the user who
is the machine that we allow to get
access to our data to our infrastructure
to our processes what can they do and in
what circumstances what are their
Privileges and how do they use it right
now when we shift it to the cloud the
permission management and the access
management dispersed it means that there
was no only one person in security that
granting permissions because we're
building the business and velocity now
devops and developers delegate access to
machines and to users all the time so
there's a full mesh of managing this
world of identity and what can they do
and when can they do it there's no
Central orchestration uh party game that
allowed to to play with it and it leads
a lot of exposure like the changes in
identities and access are being done in
a very periodic contemporary view which
opens a lot of exposure that hackers
today are exploding and using in order
to get access to your organization
right so uh what resonate brings to the
world is the ability to discover all the
identities in a very uniformic way to
create one storyline per identity per
user per organization to find these
areas of exposure and to fix them
automatically together with devops and
security teams and to protect meanings
to detect attempts to compromise this
identity and use them against the
organization and shut down these attacks
so it's a full-blown Suite uh that
covers identities from the day they are
born to the day that they are dismissed
and so if we're looking at you know
identities as a growing threat can you
touch a little bit more on you know
different use cases of where that may be
happening and and why this is a a bigger
than ever pain point right now
yes of course so uh we're delegating
nowadays A lot of the permissions and
responsibilities to machines right we
have virtual machines we have longer
functions Cloud functions and other
compute resources that are working as a
matter of fact uh the the ratio between
human flesh and Bone users and machines
is one to twenties with that now
um imagine you know the most common use
case there was a machine in the cloud
that were that was penetrated right the
attacker gained access to this machine
and now it acts on on its behalf it
grasped the role the credential the
service role that allows this machine to
operate in the cloud and laterally move
to other machines with this idea the
switching identities through the cloud
and getting the access to whatever uh
resource data or infrastructure that he
wants right until he owes the entire
account so the transitions is no longer
between machines and between network if
between identities and their
capabilities this is what happened in
Uber for example
um and a user a very strong user was
compromised his OCTA account was
compromised by an MFA fatigue attack
right the adapter triggered him to allow
the access then the attacker laterally
moved to the SAS portal okay with other
identity and then get access to all the
SAS applications and then it delegated
to another identity of this user in the
cloud in this case in AWS and
proliferated or moved laterally across
the network and across the cloud itself
the ability to connect these dots to
monitor them to respond promptly when
one is compromised and not allowing the
attacker to go to another this is the
main challenge that we're seeing today
incredible all right so so tell me a
little bit about why you're you know
you've been in the cyberspace for a long
time what is it about the cyberspace
that he gets you so excited about I mean
I you know after a long tenure in the
Cyber domain you went in into MIT Sloan
and it's obviously you're exposed to a
variety of different things around the
world that entrepreneurs would be
excited to tackle why what what is the
side or your relationship with cyber
here
well you know it goes long back to the
age of six and seven when I started to
program and the main thing was to change
the way that things are done right to
to tweak to overclock to change the
way that software is being delivered or
or Hardware is being delivered uh so
like this is this core this powder that
comes with me to every challenge or
everything that I look at is still here
right it's uh tweaking a game to add the
superhero like some more power and
stamina then you know like it's kind of
like dressed with other things when I'm
going to tackle a problem now when I
look through the MIT lens and through
the Cyber reason lands and other lenses
to the world we saw a shift a huge shift
that can you know have been done once in
a generation the cloud is the in the
next major ship after the internet that
we introduced in the 80s or 70s and as a
Defender I saw that all the old stuff
just doesn't work like I I sense the
pain of the big organizations are being
attacked and it took me back to the days
in the government that we have the same
problem so major like vast number of
attacks uh and we knew that we need to
change the party gum so the opportunity
choose to get a new thing into the
security world that will solve the major
problem that just like have been created
right like the new thing the the first
or second more Advantage here uh the the
need to change the way that we're
looking at the security world nowadays
this was the thing that drive me to do
what we're doing in resonates
wow okay and so if we're looking at sort
of a greater vision
for resonate with what you're talking
about how would you pay this greater
Vision as resonated part of the solution
so we believe that the identity will
become will have greater and greater
responsibility in the way that we're
looking at security today
we started with Cloud infrastructure
which was the most complex that needs to
be demystified for uh for both devops
and security people through the identity
lens but identity serves in estas world
as well right so we're getting you know
licenses and credentials to applications
like Salesforce and live uh netsuite and
others and then it comes to the dev area
as well as machine today grants
permission to other machines to work so
the greatest vision is that the resonate
will be uh the platform that will
Aggregate and that will recalculate the
way that these identities are working
together and near real time we'll decide
if a specific identity can get access or
not based on its posture based on the
threats that it has
um but it will or it will look and
orchestrate across all the silos that we
can see today in the identities and it
will empower the security teams to do
the work much better due to this visual
and automation
and so how how is the standard being
created for how identities should be
managed is there some uniformity or some
consistency across the world is there a
need for new types of thinking around
identity management and posture
management and and who's responsible
today for sort of setting the standard
well that's a great question like uh I
wouldn't say that it's a chaotic word
right now with just like super dispersed
and super siled
um and this is uh where resonate and
other vendors are starting to speak with
gardeners with the identity security
alliances with a lot of Trials to set a
standard over here
um we're basically doing this together
with our customers and the other vendors
so for example we have great number of
customers that works with octaves and
identity providers and with AWS as an
identity providers so we're bringing
them all in and trying to find a way to
unify uh the an orchestrate both the
data structure and the decision making
over there but there's no one single
soul today that is setting the standard
it's kind of like you know being shaped
as we're sticking right now based on
customer choices
and so in regards to
um in regards to their ability to create
thought leadership and Trust so that
your standard or your yours your your
sort of approach becomes more widely
acceptable is there are there different
things that you found to be more
effective or less effective also
considering your previous background in
understanding the cyberspace and how
security teams create Trust
yeah absolutely so like there is two
phases that we're taking or two layers
that we're working on the first one is
to be on every stage uh and every
conference and every uh webcast speaking
about the way that we believe that that
identity should be managed should be
treated across vendors and across
platforms but the second and most I
think the impactful area is to come with
true customers use cases and tailor them
down together with the vendors that are
related to this use cases for example if
Uber was penetrated through opta to AWS
and
um and security posture fell between the
lines between these two we're actually
solving this problem together with the
vendors okay we're bringing customers
that are concerned and we're building
this together and this is how do we
shape both from top down and to from
bottom up the approach to security of
the identity we also also have our own
uh code or like Manifesto or however
identity should be crafted what are the
best practices to manage it all across
security and devops and we're simulating
it right now in in the in the platform
is starting to spread the rumor across
devops teams with all sorts of social
media
um not channels and more
phenomenal so being a cyber entrepreneur
you know what what is that like so sure
there's many different types of
entrepreneurs but you've been in
cyberspace for quite some time and so
this is almost looping back to the
question of why you're excited about
cyber but what is it like being
a founder or an entrepreneur in the
cyberspace do you think it's different
from other spaces is it similar
I think there's like both similarities
and differences the main difference is
that we have the uh the theme uh of of
the good guys and the bad guys over here
right like the heroes save the day and
the vast amount of people are trying to
compromise your organization in a very
super opportunistic way there's like
opportunism versus a very structured and
systematic way uh there's uh the the
market forces are a little bit different
when it comes to cyber this is one two I
think that um cyber is more challenging
and this is what drawn me in because
there's a lot of different approaches to
solve one problem like look at the
Identity or like other markets it's it
seems saturated but it's not right the
market yet to be decide what approach to
take so uh I think that the difference
the other difference in cyber
entrepreneurs is that you need to be
very diligent in the way oh we're like
in the approach for yourself to solve a
problem you need to be very convincing
that you are the plan platform right
across like I don't know like a dozens
of offers
um and the similarities is that this
this is like a a roller coaster on
steroids right there's one day that
you're getting in front-end customers
and blowing with their minds and the day
after you have deployments and
conversion and everything worked good
and there's another day that you can
just like speak with someone that says
like listen we're we're in a recession
we don't have about like we're focusing
on the basics right now
um so with this roller coaster of
validation this roller coaster of
building things right on or focusing uh
of challenging other approaches of super
talented smart people to solve the same
problems that you're solving these are
the things that get me excited every day
right
and so you know the types of people that
you enjoy working with how do you how do
you design them order what do you who do
you find that you that you most resonate
with in terms of you know the the types
of people that you like building with
well so first of all the political say
that I like that the variety right like
the idea is this diffuse some minds of
of devops of our security people and
Security leaders together to tackle the
problem I think that there's no uh
specific person that can solve this
problem uh you know by itself but the
ones that I really like to speak with
are the ones that are not looking for
the best practice that existing out
there and then to to deploy it and
employed and then create a God that
they'll be secure like the more
open-minded can be like devops can be
csos can be cios it can be a security
practitioners like Defenders that's like
the type of people Tech or non-techy
that says listen we cannot work with 330
40 security products and and pray to God
that it will happen and to work toward
one practice we need a new approach and
this early adopters needs
um mindful
um buyers that are looking for this
solution for the world long term these
are the ones that I I really like to
work with
um
and so if you're looking at the next
year or so for resonate where are you
headed
so we're built we're finding that sweet
spot right now and building The Sweet
Spot between the cloud infrastructure
world and its identities machines or
users which can be hundreds or thousands
27 you know we're speaking even in a
small organization
to the SAS area in which you have some
sort of uh let's say islands of private
clouds of companies again like
Salesforce like o365 and others and to
connect them both together to unified
area this is what we're focusing on in
the in the coming year and moreover we
believe that you can not only do
security posture or preventive actions
you need to be in line you need to be in
real time you need to detect the
attempts of attackers to compromise the
identities you need to shut them down
based on what you're doing so the launch
of threat Detachment response on top of
the other things that we already have
um and serving different and other
personas and the more reactive world
this is where we're going with the
resume so it's like uh a vertical
approach sorry vertical approach and uh
in horizontal approach uh for this
problem identity 360. this is how we
call it I love that well I I really want
to appreciate and thank you for this for
the time you came here and I want to
wish you best of luck with resonated
sounds like uh you know this new type of
world where identity and access are you
know a critical part and the
responsibility is moving more to
machines it's it's obvious that uh that
you're that you're right there on the
you know in the right timing and and it
sounds very with a lot of intentionality
to bring your experience and excitement
towards making a big impact here for
organizations and security teams and so
I really want to thank you for spending
these 20 minutes with me I look forward
to cheering from the side and and
wishing you best of luck on the journey
thank you very much
so thank you very much it was my
pleasure thank you I appreciate it
[Music]